哈囉大家好
歡迎來到周慕姿放心說
我是周慕姿心理師
今天呢
因為我們之前有提到
很開心一件事情
就是我們的YouTube
YT十萬訂閱達成
大家看到這集的時候
應該我已經拿到獎牌了
我之前就問大家說
有沒有想要聽我閒聊
然後我發現
還蠻多人回應說
還蠻想聽我閒聊的
這一次我想跟大家分享的是
我的韓國行
其實我的韓國行說起來
沒有太多有趣的事情
因為我不是去玩
我是去表演
那我們是去韓國的Live House
表演兩天
大部分的時間
都在準備演出的事情
包含要去彩排
做一些準備
身體要休息
然後就是我們什麼器材啊
然後錄影啊等等的
就蠻多事情要做
不過呢
我還是小小的在那附近呢
度過了一點點韓國的休閒時光
所以我就覺得還蠻不錯
想跟大家分享
首先第一個是因為我們住的地方
離所謂的大家觀光客會去的
觀光區很遠
大概可能坐車要一個多小時
我們住在麻谷站附近
住在那附近的好處是什麼呢
它離金浦機場
真的很近耶
坐電車15分鐘就到了
話說回來
韓國電車也真的是蠻便宜
我本來一直覺得
韓國的一些消費
可能不會跟日本差很多
十幾年前
也是因為表演的關係
就是去了韓國
總之那個時候我就一直覺得
韓國的東西可能會比較貴
因為我沒去市中心
所以我不曉得
可是我這一次在
麻谷站附近消費
還有在我們Live House附近消費
我都覺得包含Uber
然後還有就是咖啡
然後麵包
還有就是什麼化妝品、衣服
我都覺得韓國東西
其實真的蠻便宜的
第二個是因為
我們不是住在觀光區附近
所以就是附近就都是他們生活的足跡
感覺就是
你真的是在一個跟在地人一起
然後跟韓國人生活的感覺
那感覺真的很好
然後據我們裡面的吉他手
他是工程師
他有時候也會來韓國出差
然後他就跟我說
我們現在住的附近
剛好是一個
LG蠻大的一個園區
就可能有點像我們新竹科學園區這樣
所以呢附近就有很多禮拜六早上
還要上班的社畜上班族
因為我去買咖啡的時候
我記得我其中有一天
是禮拜六早上
去就是Mega Coffee
我真的很喜歡韓國咖啡
就是又大杯又好喝又便宜
非常棒
如果去買那個咖啡的時候
就是小心不要買到什麼mix
就是即溶咖啡之類的吧
甜度的部分呢
大部分如果你有加糖的
任何的東西都會變得很甜
要跟他們講說什麼半糖啊
微糖啊像台灣這樣
可能也許因為語言的關係
不一定這麼容易哦
基本來說我都是選無糖
所以我都覺得非常好喝
然後我就在買咖啡的時候
就會看到一些就是穿著西裝
然後看起來就是
禮拜六早上還要上班
然後臉就很臭
然後我就覺得
好開心哦
我就是那個不用上班的人這樣子
我還有另外一個很好很好的經驗
是因為上一次我們來韓國的時候
大部分我們的交通
其實是當地的樂團
就是接送我們
所以我們沒有太多機會
就是坐韓國的地鐵啊
或者是跟韓國的在地人
就是一些相處
可是這一次有一些機會是我們
剛好自己會坐就是電車
往我們要去的live house方向
我們就帶著大包小包
然後就是很多器材
就在那個就是電車上面
然後馬上就有一個
看起來就會出現在韓劇
財閥家的貴婦太太
然後有一點年紀
然後看起來很有威嚴的那一種
就立刻站起來
然後就跟我說
就是他下一站就要下車了
就讓我坐
很神奇的是他是講韓文哦
我就是聽得懂他的意思是什麼
我覺得那個瞬間就覺得
自己好像吃了小叮噹的翻譯蒟蒻
那我覺得真的是太驚人了
而且在我去韓國那個時候
剛好台灣才剛就是發生那個
博愛座事件
所以我那個瞬間我就覺得
天哪
我居然被讓座了
怎麼那麼好
然後那感覺非常非常好
後來呢
我們在路上啊
或怎麼樣都有遇到
就是對我們很親切的韓國人
可能有一些事情會提醒我們啊
或是幫忙我們
我就覺得哇韓國人好親切哦
然後再來一個是我們團員
大家在討論
因為我們團員除了我之外
都是男生嘛
那你看大家都有一點年紀了
大概至少都就是三四十歲以上
所以開始會擔心什麼呢
會擔心的東西很多
但其中一個外貌的部分
焦慮的部分就是禿頭啊
所以我們其中就有團員啊
在韓國路上觀察的時候
他發現了一件事
他就說他覺得好奇怪
韓國的男生
他幾乎沒有看到幾個禿頭
他就說怎麼會這麼神奇
我們後來就是好好地觀察一下
也發現真的是
後來就是我看留言
有很多人說可能他們都有植髮
可能他們都有用什麼髮片啊
或者是就是什麼
頭髮會弄那個黑黑的粉
所以讓那個頭髮看起來比較多
我們就開始在討論一個可能性
這個是沒有科學根據
這就是我們在聊天
因為我們裡面的其中一個團員
也就是我們鼓手
他是醫生
他就講說
禿頭真的是一個非常吃基因
而且完全就是一個絕症的狀況
所以我們就在開始在討論說
是不是因為韓國人有吃人蔘
那時候看人蔘皂苷是用在頭髮上
會很有幫助嘛
所以我們就想說
他們是會把人蔘拿去頭上塗嗎
還是我們每天吃人蔘也有用呢
因為比例上真的差很多
韓國包含年紀很大的人
就是很少看到那種就是全禿
或是中間禿一塊什麼
就幾乎沒有看到
所以也有可能真的像大家講的
就是他們真的對外貌很在意
所以就是這個樣子
不知道有沒有對韓國很熟的朋友
知道為什麼這樣
然後可以就是留言讓我們知道
就也很謝謝大家
然後當然啦
這一次去韓國呢
大家就多多少少還是會買東西
因為我們其實沒有機會去太多地方玩
以女生來說
買東西最有興趣的就是
跟麗珠蘭有關的所有的相關產品
然後大家就是會狂購
聽說觀光區有很多藥妝店
然後買這些東西很困難
那的確因為我那邊就不是觀光區嘛
所以我那邊隨便去一個藥局
你要買什麼全部都有
他們就會看到你跟他講照片
然後全部都出來
所以就非常方便
另外我覺得還有一個蠻有趣的地方是
表演完都會有那種
大家會一起去吃個飯
通常這個情況呢
韓國的樂團
幾乎都是帶我們去吃烤肉店
所以就是那個很大塊的三層肉
然後我記得我們
在第一次去韓國烤肉的時候
那時候是在釜山附近
所以就是去了一個很神秘的店
那真的是我
這輩子吃過最好吃的韓國烤肉
真的沒有之二
即使我這一次去韓國
他們在地人帶我們去的首爾的烤肉店
我也覺得很好吃
那一家真的太好吃了
就是它的肉
還有所有的東西都非常非常棒
而且最恐怖的事情是
那個肉就很像是那個
日本有那個小碗麵嘛
就是麵會就是一直
你沒吃完它就一直加進去
我們那一次就是大盤肉
烤盤上
肉只要剩下一點點
老闆就突然衝出來
他不知道從哪裡衝出來
然後就又把一大塊三層肉放在上面
我後來是要把蓋子蓋起來
跟他說不用了不用了
我們不要再吃了
吃肉吃到怕這樣子
這一次我們在韓國
我去吃了兩家烤肉店
一家是山清
是我們自己的就是團員
帶我們去吃
然後就也在麻谷跟鉢山站附近
聽說它那一間店就是總店
那好像是在東大門還哪裡
就是它也有一間分店
就觀光客排隊要排很久
我覺得因為我們那邊附近
不知道是不是因為LG園區
烤肉喝酒店就超級多
大家壓力都很大
一下班就要衝去吃
我真的覺得那間店很讚耶
真的很讚
就是除了那個氣氛
因為我們去總店
然後也許附近沒有什麼觀光客
你大概可以感覺到裡面外國人
只有我們這一桌
然後那個幫我們烤的那個弟弟啊
好可愛哦
他還因為我一直看著肉
可能是我一直看著肉
然後口水快要流出來
然後一直看一直看
他還用那個Google翻譯寫說
我會把它烤得很好吃的
你放心
然後我們團員就說
你看起來一定很貪吃
所以人家要特別跟你這樣說
那家店我非常非常推薦
整個氣氛
然後還有就是收費
我們其實吃了很多
但整個收費上
我覺得是非常合理的
我吃得非常飽
我食量很大
而且我們吃很多肉
然後它菜什麼的也有一些
所以我記得我們平均一個人
大概就是五六百塊
雖然他們排隊的桌數很多
但是因為他們翻桌率很快
很多人就是吃一吃
然後就走了
他可以線上等位
所以大家有興趣的話
可以參考看看
然後另外呢
就是我們那個在地的韓國樂團
帶我們去吃的那家店呢
感覺更在地了
阿珠媽的臉很臭
然後呢
現場就是大家就喝酒啊
很大聲啊
就跟我們看韓劇那個
很開心那個狀況很像
那因為帶我們去的是韓國樂團
所以我們也有機會
第一次喝到韓國的深水炸彈
燒酒是百分之二十
然後剩下是啤酒
然後他們有那個神秘比例
調然後就給你喝這樣子
在那個時候
其實會看到
蠻多文化的特殊性
覺得很有趣
如果他跟你感情好的話
會發生一件事
什麼事情
他會直接夾給你吃
然後我覺得我在那個現場
真的是覺得太震驚了
就是
我就在想是
身為台灣人都覺得這麼震驚了
如果是日本人的話
應該會崩潰吧
因為我們去年跟前年
才去日本巡回
所以我們也跟日本的一些樂團
在當地就是一起吃飯啊幹嘛的
他們會有很多他們自己的習慣
那因為我們比較常去日本
所以很熟悉
那韓國人跟日本人
真的是完全不一樣的
所以我在現場被餵了好幾次
這個習慣
對有些人來說
其實很快的會讓你覺得感情很好
因為畢竟這個食物的交換
就是跟台灣人一樣嘛
就幫你夾菜的那個感覺
但台灣人只是夾到你碗裡
他是夾到你嘴巴裡
那個情感的親密度
就又變得完全不一樣
然後另外在文化上
還有一個蠻有趣的觀察是
大家大概很難想象
你去韓國
你講英文
不一定可以通
我很意外的是
不管是上一趟也好
或這一趟也好
不少人會跟我們講日文
我包含海關
我也有遇到海關
就直接跟我講日文
不知道是因為
他就覺得我們是日本人嗎
還是怎麼樣
他日文講得還不錯
或者是說在我們這一群
就是韓國的樂團朋友裡面
也是有人
就是我們在講英文的時候
他聽不太懂
在聊天過程
居然有講一兩句日文的時候
我們就試探性的問問看說
欸那講日文可以嗎
他們說可以哦
我們居然是在韓國
一個韓國人跟一個台灣人
最後是用日文在交流
這件事情我覺得非常非常特別
韓國的確有一群人是很喜歡日本的
那時候在跟韓國樂團聊天
他們有時候
可能也會接待一些日本樂團
或是他們自己非常喜歡日本的文化
所以他們自己就會去學日文
因此甚至像我之前遇到的
那一個韓國的樂團的團長
他會講日文是因為他太太就是日本人
這一次我大概遇到至少六、七次
有人就是看到我們的時候
直接跟我們講日文
而且講的其實都還不錯
這件事情讓我非常的驚訝
這是我在韓國文化的另外一個觀察
那最後啊
今天就是韓國閒聊嘛
所以真的是閒聊
那我不知道大家喜不喜歡
我分享這些很奇怪的小觀察
那因為呢
今天講的是韓國
身為一個女孩子
對不起
我這個就是
不要跟我戰性別歧視
拜託
就是因為我個人就是喜歡
大家去韓國最常做的就是買彩妝嘛
今天就是有一個非常大的bonus
就是我從來沒有分享過這種東西
但是因為之前也有一些人
會在YT上留言說
老師你今天口紅用什麼顏色或什麼的
所以我就想說
那我乾脆來分享一下
我最近很喜歡的彩妝
而且剛好是韓國品牌
今天完全沒有業配
就是真的是我個人花錢
我自己喜歡買
然後跟大家分享
首先第一個
最近使用我很喜歡的一個口紅的品牌
它叫做AOU
它有很多很多顏色
我為什麼很喜歡它呢
它是那種很滋潤的
特別是去韓國啊
日本這種天氣很乾的地方
你還要上口紅
你就一定要再上一個護唇膏
那有時候你再上一個護唇膏
再上唇膏的時候
其實還是會有一點唇紋
這一款就是很不錯
因為它也有護唇膏的效果
所以幾乎有時候
我是可以完全不需要上護唇膏
直接上上去
然後整個就是看起來就是
很滋潤的感覺
讓我自己還蠻喜歡
我覺得比較不方便的地方
就是因為它是這種瓶裝嘛
所以你可能需要就是
譬如說用刷具
或是像我比較懶
有時候會用就是
手指直接塗上去
這樣手就會油油的
這就比較是比較麻煩的地方
但是是好用的東西
所以我還蠻喜歡的
那接下來
我想要直接
分享一個彩妝品牌
我覺得它真的是
我好喜歡
我真的覺得很好用欸
一開始接觸
是因為它的腮紅
這個品牌叫
DEAR DAHLIA
D-E-A-R
D-A-H-L-I-A
總之它就是一個
液態的腮紅
點在臉上
把它推開之後
看起來會很自然
現在臉上擦的就是
第一個是它的
妝感很不強
我很喜歡很淡妝
看起來很自然
不然我以前不太喜歡畫腮紅
因為我一直覺得
腮紅不小心一下重手
像我這種手拙的人
就很容易看起來就是
很紅哦
所以我其實不太喜歡畫腮紅
那這個就是它可以畫得很自然
而且它可以疊加
所以你顏色是
每天都可以隨你個人心情調整
即使手拙如我
也可以畫出
看起來會被那個化妝師稱讚說
欸老師你今天化妝很自然耶
的妝
好的
那也可能是化妝師只是安慰我而已
但是我自己很喜歡
所以我後來又嘗試了
它的唇膏跟它的眼線
然後我還是要講
就是眼線是我用過
我覺得最好畫的
不管是眼線的細度
還有整個顏色以及暈染度
就是我覺得還是會有一點暈
但是真的不嚴重
整個就是持妝度非常非常高
主要是又好畫
所以我個人是覺得
它現在是我心中眼線第一名
那最後就是它的唇膏
其實它的唇膏
跟剛剛我說的那個AOU很像
就是滋潤度很高
持色度也不錯
而且就是我本來就很喜歡
護唇膏系的潤色唇膏
它的那個使用起來
嘴巴看起來就是
水潤水潤的感覺
而且它也很適合疊加
不過我覺得
因為每個人的唇色不一樣
所以有時候畫上去的感覺
可能也會不太相同
那如果你剛好去韓國的話
大部分都是可以試色的
所以蠻鼓勵大家可以試色之後
再看看適不適合你
請注意
我不是團購
我也不是在推銷大家買東西
只是分享我個人有興趣的品牌
因此適不適合
你還是要試試看哦
那這就是
今天周小慕
第一次就是分享彩妝品牌
是不是要往彩妝YouTuber開始邁進
並沒有
好的
那麼這一次韓國行
大概分享到這裡
也希望大家喜歡
我的這個囉哩八唆的小分享
那如果喜歡的話
也歡迎可以留言讓我知道
或是你想聽我分享
什麼日常生活的小瑣事
那麼周慕姿放心說
我們下次見囉
拜拜